[Music]
and Finders Keepers news losers weepers
Beach hmm
submitted by Ken doll are you telling
them it's not being cute okay no don't
need to give it to him it smells good
a homeless couple who found $350,000 are
now on trial for money laundering Oh cuz
it was laundered money well cuz there
they didn't pay taxes on it I guess oh
is it because they were panhandling
really well and they got $350,000 they
pay their taxes they found a duffel bag
full of money
you start panhandling dude trust me
you're gonna fail
I wouldn't feel sorry for you look at
you you know I put on a quite a scene
let me see give me give me a taste let
me get some money money money money let
me get somebody plea for something I
can't do it I guess one Asian homeless
guy in Little Tokyo I don't know what he
is but he looks like a asian Rastafarian
guy and he's always got like two little
toes wiggling outside of his shoes I
never seen that time hey you've seen him
because he came up and he goes
yeah that same singsong me sir do you
have any chance
a car you have to change and in his
little toe like Wiggles where he has a
shoe but it's like four to two toes and
in and I was thinking like he was a dark
dark asian guy like his tan and I looked
really close and I was like dang dude
what do you do rub yourself in [ __ ]
tire rubber like he was all like all
covered in it right and he has a lot of
track marks so I think he likes heroin
yeah
but he appears out of the Mist and he
goes that's actually a really good
description when I met that guy he was
with Joe and then you don't know who
he's talking to
yeah yeah he's in look at you didn't
look at you so I'm like who are you
asking changed from there's like 12
people here so it's just like you do it
talking down to the floor
yeah view smiles and he's super happy
about it I give Joe change I would I
look I look miserable yeah yeah anyway
this homeless couple here so they're
from Belgium Belgium and they were
squatting in an abandoned building where
they found an old Singer sewing machine
and inside of that sewing machine was
three hundred thousand euros that's it
you're done you're good that's a dream
comes on what the [ __ ] is the problem
you know it's resent money because it's
euros oh so that's some drug money [ __ ]
or maybe that's what the estimated value
is is they just put it in yours but it
could have been in francs or it could
have been in whatever they call euros no
I mean like after they appraised it to
show you what it is
baby's converting like if they found
Civil War money they're not gonna say
like in medallions
I don't know well I mean it's usable
money because they gave it away to
friends that's why you're poor you can't
give you away your money still bid you
keep it for yourself [ __ ] your friends
and family man it's not enough where
were they when you were homeless well
what if they're all other homeless
friends that helped them out when they
were probably all they're homeless
friends share it if I had a million
three hundred thousand is not enough
that's just enough to get your life
started again you know what I mean like
if you have a million then yeah half
that give it to your friends the other
half and you keep it yourself mean ten
thousand to get started again and so the
couple his name is Joey was 32 years old
and Kimberly is 33 oh that's so young to
be homeless why do they got American
names in Belgium and it's interesting
yeah was a Belgium name yeah what is it
there'd be some French name oh really
they speak French there Oh jock German
Jean Pierre oh they're in the right in
the middle
I could easily know they speak Furman
you're lying cuz it's German
no it's German or French or French it
says the country has regions including
Dutch speaking in the North French
speaking in the South and German
speaking in the intelligence they do a
little Fuhrman so it sounded like he
wasn't sure that's right I'm like French
in German in French I thought it was
like a term of you're like you drove
through Belgium because you were in
France yeah Gunther and Gretchen
yeah matter that Camberley and who Joey
and Joey yeah that's interesting to me
they watch American TV shows their
parents well how did they how do they
get caught
yeah wow I got caught because when they
were staying at a friend's home that
friend's home had like a big there was a
drug raid and so they were searched they
searched the authorities searched the
property and all shady character that
Joey had 50,000 euros and
- on him what he'd do with the other
money investigation they found out
somehow that they found that that amount
of money that they had given it to nine
people yeah
and so now the couple and the nine
people are all involved in this whole
thing where the couple is now being
charged with money laundering and why do
you rat out his other friends or why
even say the amount that you found yeah
that's this whole not cut people are
[ __ ] done I don't think they actually
found that money though I feel like they
probably didn't actually find the money
it might be money laundering like
they're all selling drugs and they're
like oh we just found this money we
don't have to pay a tax well apparently
the owner of the abandoned building said
that he wants the cash return oh oh he
did hide it or maybe he heard 350 I need
that returned I've been saving it for a
rainy day and he has to show receipt and
paper trail to say that it's his my in
hiding it in an old sewing machine
Katrina
yeah so now prosecutors are seeking
18-month suspended prison sentences and
fines of six thousand euros for each
that's it each person what would you do
for a Klondike bar probably do something
gay how do they even know to look inside
a sewing machine that's crazy let's take
that apart let some crackhead question
is how big is that sewing machine my god
for $300,000 that big yeah I was like
this big I got industrial it was like
this this thing it was like this the big
eyes like half of this table and yeah
the penalty that goes couldn't even fit
my Google's old old Singer sewing
machine it has like a whole table with
it yeah if you go to like All Saints
they have a billion sewing machines in
the front I mean I don't know this one
but I hope my grandma has some [ __ ] like
where do you hide it though
maybe the drawers
and the owner of the house forgot to
check the drawers a abandoned building
maybe it was an industrial one because
it looks like hi man if I was out of my
luck I would never share $350,000
nothing happened well I guess if you're
homeless it's not like you really care
about being financially sound yeah I
think they're just they can work there
are 30 years old they're just runaway
drug dealers that's so dumb you can
[ __ ] crack with drugs at that home
I'd do the same if I was I mean like
obviously they're not trying to get on
their feet and live with society if
you're 30 years old you know you're
capable you're not down yeah you're not
down and out like [ __ ] you could find a
job because if you're like 70 something
and it's like yeah people won't hire you
yeah would you move away you Bobby buy a
house put a down payment on payment on a
house and buy no [ __ ] house on hell
nah man it's like all your money already
no no like three hundred thousand I
could get back on my feet people do do
it on less that's true that's what I'm
saying only is 10 G's man we could play
the bankrupt game that'll be fun if
everyone's like hey all right for you
gotta you have 24 months to get back on
your feet or some [ __ ] and then you
can't use any money here's $100 now I'm
gonna drop you off in the middle of the
Vietnam or some [ __ ] well let's say you
have $200 that's pretty good fit yeah
that's pretty good
what would you do like what's the first
thing you do with $10,000 in America it
depends on where I'm at so you're out
you're [ __ ] out of luck you're [ __ ]
homeless just left do you just by
yourself am I allowed to still like use
social media how do you pay for all that
stuff it's $10,000 I could get a phone
that's right yeah and so it's just a
free world media what are you gonna do
you're starting from scratch you're
handicapped scratch starting from
scratch your new alias is now so John
wasabi no access to the people that I
built contacts with no no access to
nothing no you're starting from scratch
huh you're John wasabi now no one even
knows who's sabi don't even know Georgia
two colors I got luscious lips let me
tell you that
go straight into dick-suck rate and
today you're getting move girl what the
tip of dick I mean with 10 G's I would
get like a motel or somewhere where I
could temporarily live and I would get
the best kind of clothes I can find and
then I will go out and try to get like a
temporary job and then I would save up
monthly to get a small roommate
situation where I could get an address
then when I get an address I got to get
my ID I got to get my [ __ ] you
know all the paperwork done like I'm a
[ __ ] resident like I have a
house that you could mail [ __ ] to you
wouldn't do any of this that I could
only handled not life right now with all
of these resources and with me as your
assistant you would not I was in almost
40 K debt and I [ __ ] did the exact
thing right here BAM sure did I remember
I like how in this whole scenario the
first thing you didn't think was to
reach out to your friends communicating
over by myself
yeah I was like oh come stay with us for
as long as you want with 10 G's starting
from scratch let's do it
[Music]
[Music]